while chromatography
separates compounds depending on their
chemical and physical properties
mass spectrometry or mass spec as it is
commonly known
reveals a compound's molecular weight
in a mass spectrophotometer a beam of
electrons bombards a single chemical
sample with enough energy to break apart
molecules
the fragments produced are propelled
through a magnetic field
and automatically sorted according to
their mass and charge
an ion detector collects and records the
fragments
producing a graph showing the mass to
charge ratio of each
to analyze the information and deduce
the structure of the original molecule
a scientist must work backward
reassembling the fragments on paper
when all goes well they fit together
like puzzle pieces
to reveal the composition of the
original sample